was that laying around as I can that
face all the bad spirits out of it
BAM here we go right from the [__]
jump to let you know what type of
Wednesday night this is it's filled with
some banana G from the [__] perennial
as usual wait till you see this [__]
here this is whatever the [__] this is
this is doe Seco look at this [__] here
this is the thing that hit Bruce Willis
in the head you [__] look at these
[__] budget dosey doe but we're gonna
open up with a banana OG just to get the
[__] room level you know I'm saying
there's bitty thoughts my laws
oh [__] smooth that should be the name
of this week's smooth in the Stanley
just like that so Wednesday night I hope
you had a great day I missed you
[__] I've been a little under the
weather you know traveling [__] you up
makes you a little [__] up but thank
God Lisa adds here tonight the dual [__]
he's been bugging me for two days what
are we doing bong it's one we doing bong
it's one we gonna find the ship has
arrived understatement
look at that that's [__] beauty look
at that [__] this beautiful model
taking all this [__] out of your body
open the scout start coughing in a
couple minutes
the guy next dog dude stop [__]
coughing hilarious
we gave him a dose of this shitty and
it's all over when you lurking for this
[__] neighborhood of the office
building it's all over there's a thing
that you step on this is you dare until
this [__] house nice and light this
is nice training material game I'm
saying we're here we're queer
I'm happy you joined us that's right
[__] by the shit's going on why
the moves are being made brief is
getting smoked and let it [__] you
you know it'll be fun cuz I'm saying I
call you I fax you nothing I sent a new
but the house to pick you up you think
you [__] call me back nothing
like the [__] this banano Gigli
this is the [__]
there's the [__] that killed Lincoln and
we'll caboose right here this is the
[__] right here give me a little tab for
that right there's no misunderstanding
that meal [__] let's do this [__]
do this [__] do this [__] do this [__]
tremendous you understand me I've been
tellin you [__] for weeks where
you've been
I'm here waiting on you nobody shows up
[__] yeah this is the batch of death
right here tonight
from one against tremendous huh
you call me beautiful after we do here
we get you going you understand me well
if it's in the morning at night I always
got the materials to get you going
whether it's motivational inspiration
some reefer [__] edible there's always
something coming over here do you some
uncle Joey I'm saying that's the beauty
of this shirt just [__] think that I'm
not a hemophiliac I'll be bleeding for
[__] days
beautiful you ready for one more nervous
this when you going to check the lung
and [__] you suppose this is why this
reefer dog right now medium-size
nobody's feelings get hurt
oh yeah there's a good [__] night
already understand me ladies and
gentlemen we got edibles we got
everything here we got [__] methylene
Xanadu hauling company
we got everything [__] how's that
is that really is what we're talking
about people you don't want to be
[__] around with [__] up such plant
a weed if you're gonna go to the town go
to town [__]
when you blow the smoke out he knows
that's tremendous that's a that's a nice
I'm saying tough for the [__] nails
these Jews you gotta hit him in the head
with a bat
they wouldn't even die at SeaWorld these
[__] SeaWorld can't kill these
[__] juice that's out tom de gallo
it's a beautiful Wednesday night the
door is open the Sun is at least coffee
we got [__] reefer for days [__]
rid of the taste that's the only way to
live it up video game California we got
stars just put the night cream that
starts today we have to split three
[__] stars and we got that sucker get
the blood going 302 it's 500 most people
need 500 a [__] week we're still a
training hey [__]
just like that is gone down the [__]
hatch had a little halibut tonight my
wife made a little chump [__] spinach
salad with [__] red onions in it I'm
ready to go
you don't say little [__] up stone but
who gives a [__] well there's a will
there's a way if I'm not puking of dying
I'm here with you [__] tremendous
edible thanks for that junk is your bad
breath on the [__] headache and you
got nothing leaves that [__] in there
right you got a party with uncle Joey
I'm bringing the [__] good you know
I'm saying look at this look at the
[__] goods right there look at how
beautiful this is 55 a [__] they won't
they won't you picked this little stem
right here and you massage your little
dick hole it's all oh but the shot you
know they're [__] [__] you ain't
got a sense of humor why you [__] with
uncle Joey then you know we got some
also we got something
TKO [__] TKO [__] this
is this is [__] this [__] [__] that
Holly Holm think I'm the Rosen head with
that this is a TKO [__]
you ain't getting up from this most
people who survive these details but we
don't give a [__] yet the church we're
always taking it to the next level
thanks to you [__] keep us in
check all these other hope you don't be
talking [__] what [__] sparking like
soldiers eat we don't [__] around here
and spin it awesome my little bat
one-shot deal he who hesitates
masturbates I'm saying drop it on you
[__] nothing but empty bags and
containers and hopes over here so show
up now tons of reefer but the goods are
Gus
if you the police don't even think about
it concept you have to take us down to
the station [__] this [__] my stomach
like Columbia music because I'm
professional ain't got time I could open
those things in the dark will
replenishing the [__] what do you
think delicious nutritious low carbs
with the leaves eyeball show America
mostly that's an eyeball ladies and
gentlemen you understand me yeah show me
eyeball again you see that eyeball right
there that's a [__] eyeball people
his eyeballs don't look like that
you know what shoot yourself right now
go eat hummus don't even leave a note
they know you're [__] too insane
they know you're [__] why [__]
around like I said it's a beautiful
night to be alive here and nothing but
bond hits for planet is like the
Thanksgiving upon its turn to lead a
double life little cars can do 1981 how
to tell you guys something you might not
have liked me after this but if I got to
pick five out this is one of my favorite
[__] hounds of all second cars out
first one was a monster they came back
with a [__] killer for the second
people don't do that [__] a lot of
people shoot that load on the [__]
first one and they argue about money who
looks better on camera and then they get
it together by the third or four
thousand these [__] came out
with a second I'll have to jump like Run
DMC
nothing to do just keep doing fine heads
until you kill over something pops out
because that's how we do it here so
Wednesday night people
everybody wants a party on the Friday
and Saturday
listen 7:24 that's our motto here this
could pop up on your screen 724 we're
doing bong hits like savages tellingly
don't just sit there with your little
blue and white shirt give them say
please go there's a little blue and
white temple [__] busting up tonight
he's definitely probably down with the
laundry
what's tremendous I got no regrets they
say I should have got a high school
diploma she left a lot of things but I
got no [__] two regrets I got my GED
I got I got mainly [__] a time same
place you know I'm saying you just don't
suck the [__] [__] you gotta leave
the [__] to and play the kazoo you
know I'm saying put the site by them put
your hand by the [__] and blowing ass
let's see what happens you never did
that that's old school right [__] you
feel at this she's a [__] don't feel
nothing nothing comes up it's saying you
know you've been [__] swiped again
saying that's how you know you gotta get
your life together you gotta get by the
classes and you gotta get better friends
so we're here what do you got planned
for the weekend who gives a [__] it's
Wednesday I'm not even looking for
[__] Friday I'm looking for tonight
looking for Thursday to make a move
there's tremendous just to have this
[__] opportunity in America just
smoke [__] weed on a TV [__]
channel with your goombazz look at this
we live in like duck they can't compete
with us no more
Isis is watching so be careful
oh [__]
there's the one right here baby boy you
drive around in Italian cars cars cars
cars wishing you a star star star look
at this [__] beauty ladies and
gentlemen if this beauty why is it that
you don't care if that seconds right
there wait
like a soldier double aa superset of
Barney Lou a superset of - by himself
you understand they said once y'all pull
up to lunch
they can't stop there's no turning back
once I open my ballet need help
wait I open up the mouth that's what
smoke let's make won't mind one one
there's a fire fire people show up is
two fat [__] in the room watch the
[__] millions
don't tell me what to do Scooby red
couple more bondage with it this podcast
started and that said you don't saying
we're gonna mano a mano
tonight Marty the mono [__] oh
[__] oh [__] oh [__]
oh [__] can do I need you oh [__]
oh [__]
remember when people tell you by
partying this is a [__] party poured
out of the [__] you don't need eyes open
this is a [__] party that's about an
hour you need a [__] chicks ass bag
in the face just to seem normal
right now this is a party right here so
we some family some friends with
pedaling you [__] [__]
I love you
Denver get your tickets now they're
going like [__] Chinese hookers in
North Hollywood they're gonna quit
[__] so you better go down and get
your [__] tickets cuz we're rockin
this weekend I'll bring an old school
with no school putting it together
I'm not going to Boulder because I might
shoot people
something says behave myself and [__]
temper him bleep are you ready for
another bucket here tonight oh [__] just
what he sells now we can't give Li
little more fun he's gonna run the
[__] show we don't want to show what
happens never [__] show it from you
don't [__] it up
that's like a [__] 500 TAC and with
snowing buckling in will hold up no why
what set an example for you
[__] that's why huh who else
eats these [__] things are funny and
let you know he loves you nobody at him
I told you a thousand times on my uncle
[__] Joey you understand you got
these families your [__] up you don't
know who your father is but guess what
you know your uncle is wooow that's
cooool [__] and your cousin is
[__] this right here this beauty this
suppose who shows up a little [__]
bouncer
can you imagine we show up but your
[__] house for a weekend
hey so it's over anyway you're talking
about it's over we all get this [__]
show started I enjoy my little tape
Dante's with you people from the bottle
of mine I tell them the hell look
forward to it should I love you thought
except to say I was busy I was making
moves a mil here a mil there and should
happens you get confused but I'm back
back like a bad [__] you
understand me Denver tomorrow Friday
sadly next week where I'm at the ice
house I'm a [__] the red horse the
black horse up down Reseda we're at
[__] were in a million places next
Tuesday
next week you understand we're just
working out the specially deadline is
October 15th I gotta be tip-top told me
to goo and if not I'm a [__] failure
what are you gonna do what do you do
miss I am what the [__] are you gonna do
you can't complain as long as you give
it your [__] all that's always you
give me that old [__] Israeli try
they can't [__] with you you understand
me you know Jerusalem try you gotta go
down swinging in the [__] trenches of
debt gets a [__] what happens to you
ain't dying you swing it you're being
you [__] get out there you got a
dream who gives a [__] with this guy
things go for it right or wrong he
wanted to be an editor he ended up a
punk-ass producer what do you do you see
I'm saying sometimes your dreams are
[__] up yeah they couple you different
[__] sizes but at least you got a
dream anyway we'll get this [__] show
started what channels are only
youtube.com / c / OBS youtube.com / c /
joey [__] will see you [__] in
a few minutes get ready to rock alright
I'm happy you tuned them I'm happy you
got your head together whew 18 hang up
now no problem that I'm gonna hear from
your mother - mom Joe even my son smoked
the [__] ammonia I don't need that
[__] in my life Sofie I'm 19 hang up now
[__] if not I love yous
[__] along my heart
we'll be on the podcast in a few take
care yourself here